Se nos dice que: "Un atleta hace una respiración
profunda e inhala 1.85 L de aire a 21°C y 754
mm de Hg. ¿Cuántos moles de aire hay en su
inhalación? ¿Cuántas moléculas hay?" Pausa este
video y ve si puedes resolverlo por tu cuenta.
Muy bien, ahora trabajemos juntos en esto. Así
que pensemos en lo que nos están dando y en lo que
necesitamos descubrir. Entonces nos dan un volumen
justo aquí, también nos dan una temperatura justo
aquí, también nos dan la presión, y quieren que
encontremos la cantidad de moles. Voy a usar
un color verde aquí. A menudo usamos la letra
minúscula n para representar el número de moles.
Entonces, ¿conocemos algo que relacione presión,
temperatura, volumen y cantidad de moles? Bueno,
quizá estés pensando en la Ley de los gases
ideales, que nos dice que la presión multiplicada
por el volumen es igual a la cantidad de moles,
n, por la constante de los gases ideales, R,
por la temperatura T [PV = nRT]. Conocemos
todo excepto n, entonces podemos despejar n. Sé
que algunos de ustedes están pensando "Espera,
¿conocemos R?". Bueno, R es una constante y la
versión que usemos dependerá de las unidades que
manejemos. Por eso es que tengo esta pequeña tabla
que podrías ver en un formulario si estuvieras
presentando un examen a P, por ejemplo, así
que en realidad conocemos el valor de R,
sólo necesitamos despejar n. Entonces, para
despejar n simplemente dividimos ambos lados entre
rT y así obtendremos que n es igual a la presión
multiplicada por el volumen sobre R multiplicado
por T, ¿y esto será igual a qué? Bueno, nuestra
presión es de 754 milímetros de mercurio. Ahora,
aquí donde tenemos las diferentes versiones de
la constante de los gases ideales no vemos que
alguna de ellas estén en milímetros de mercurio,
pero sí nos dicen que 1 milímetro de mercurio es
igual a 1 Torr. Si quieres ser muy, muy preciso,
éstos son ligeramente diferentes, pero para los
propósitos de una clase de Química básica puedes
considerar 1 milímetro de mercurio como 1 Torr.
Entonces puedes ver la presión aquí como 754
Torr. Permíteme escribir esto: esto es 754 Torr;
y luego vamos a multiplicar eso por el volumen.
Aquí hay varias versiones que están en litros,
probablemente usaremos esta, esta versión de la
constante de los gases ideales que está en litros,
Torr, moles y Kelvin. Entonces multipliquemos
por el volumen, por 1.85 litros y luego eso se
dividirá entre la constante de los gases ideales.
Usaré esta versión porque involucra todas las
unidades que ya tengo. Y sé lo que estás pensando:
"Espera. La temperatura se da en grados Celsius",
pero es fácil convertir grados Celsius a
Kelvin, sólo tienes que agregar 273 a lo
que tengas en grados Celsius porque ninguno de
esto se da en grados Celsius. Así que usaré esta
constante de los gases ideales. Esto será 62.36
L Toor / mol • K. Mol a la -1 es sólo 1 / mol,
así que puedo escribirlo así: K¯¹ es 1/K, y
luego multiplicaré por la temperatura. Entonces,
¿a qué equivalen 21°C en términos de Kelvin?
Bueno, sumo 273 a eso, entonces serán 294
Kelvin. Y podemos validar que todas las unidades
funcionen: este litro se cancela con este litro,
este Torr se cancela con este Torr, este que
Kelvin se cancela con este Kelvin; y así nos
quedaremos con algunos cálculos. Y va a ser 1
sobre 1 sobre mol, o esencialmente se simplificará
como un cierto número de moles. Ahora saquemos
nuestra calculadora para calcular la cantidad de
moles en esa inhalación. Entonces n será igual a
754 x 1.85 dividido entre 62.36, y luego también
dividido entre 294; es igual a todo esto.
Veamos cuántas cifras significativas tenemos:
tenemos tres aquí, tres aquí, tres aquí, cuatro
aquí. Entonces, cuando estamos multiplicando y
dividiendo queremos usar la menor cantidad de
cifras con la que estemos tratando, por lo que
vamos a usar tres cifras significativas. Entonces,
0.0 uno, dos, tres cifras significativas,
queda 0.0761, esto va a ser 0.0761. Y podría decir
aproximadamente porque estoy redondeando, pero
aquí hay tres cifras significativas, entonces esta
es la cantidad de moles de aire en la inhalación.
Ahora, la siguiente pregunta es ¿cuántas moléculas
hay en ella? Bueno, sabemos que cada mol tiene
aproximadamente 6.022 x 10²³ moléculas, por lo
que sólo tenemos que multiplicar esto por 6.022
x 10²³, entonces podríamos escribirlo de esta
manera, podríamos escribir 0.761 mol x 6.022
x 10²³ moléculas por mol. Ahora estos se
cancelarán y sólo me quedarán moléculas. Y voy a
usar el número que tengo en la calculadora porque
es bueno mantener la precisión hasta que tengamos
que pensar en las cifras significativas, porque
ya hicimos todo este cálculo y vamos a querer
redondear todo a tres cifras significativas.
Entonces multipliquemos esto por 6.022,
EE significa "10 a la", 10²³, que es igual a
eso; y si redondeo a tres cifras significativas
debido a que en todo mi cálculo esa fue
mi restricción de cifras significativas,
tengo 4.58 x 10²², entonces esto es 4.58
x 10²² moléculas. Y con esto terminamos.